the 90s were the best time of all time
and the toys rocked and life was great
pic clips it's like 60 seconds of one's
oh it's not even a song why it's the
only part I remember of that song is
that 60 seconds of it if hit me baby one
more time isn't on this I'm walking why
are they children what things with one
earphone like you can't shut your
parents out with one earphone well this
feels like something that Zenon would
have cuz it's like kind of futuristic
but also extremely shitty was there
volume can you just volume it's perfect
the way it is amazing where you've gone
where we've gone in the past 10 years
were like this amount of storage can now
this is like everything whereas back
then it was equivalent to one oops I did
it again
not even Tamagotchis this was a good
idea until you realized that it could
die and you had to care for it but eat
it in the morning go to school I'd race
home and rush to it and try to save its
life before it died and it always died
in my offer this one's already pooped
it's already gonna clean it oh my god
there's three buttons how come I don't
know how to use this little button well
no I don't know what's happening there's
a bunch of heart I think that's good
Tamagotchi just kind of moves left and
right with his mouth randomly opening
this is a skip it but it's not a skip it
it's just like the Walmart skip it my
favorite ones were the ones that like
they had a counter on it what do I do
how do you get it going there you go oh
my harder than I remember I'm not saying
I'm gonna be great at this but I will be
graded okay let's see it okay well yeah
Keith Yackey there you go all right here
we go yep it let's see if you can skip
up to the top we're 90 skids just a
really good shape yeah was it's a smelly
gag oh come on
you could order this right out of
Nickelodeon magazine please Oh what is
that smell it's the worst smell isn't it
crazy that kids are there's a demand for
kids to have like awful smelling toys
it feels sweaty who can make it the
fastest huh rule on baking like I have a
booger pop it first generation bop it
because Bop it got WAY crazy after this
you would just get so dialed in in the
commercials I was always the coolest
thing was they were like always like
popping it on their hip this stressed me
out incredibly no choose kid powered
anti-gravity shoes you want to hold my
hands I would not because I need to but
because I want to be there in town wow
this feels unsafe Oh guys okay that's
enough okay is that how you play with
them you just jump around it's like
you're walking on the moon
it's just buckets and bands and velcro I
want to jump like they jump in the
commercials baby I am NOT jumping
anything
I think moon shoes should come back what
I like about 90s toys is there's just a
little bit more danger there's not like
a Taylor Swift from 1989 hit clips alive
to me is there she pulled her off her
music off of Spotify and put it onto
tiger hit clips